i'm here at the beijing winter olympics
and this atm machine is just called my
eye they are not just normal atm
machines that allow you to deposit or
withdraw cash they also let
international visitors and participants
to the games to exchange their foreign
bank bills into the digital unit
let's just try it out
um i have here with me a 20 bill
so now i'm going to insert this
with
the equivalent amount of 20 dollars of
easy wine with me on this car
you can go to almost every point of
sales inside the olympics bubble we have
the dining halls and then the
merchandise stores
you can use the ecm y physical card to
pay for all of these things
so i just found out a coffee shop here i
just ordered a americano
and i'm tapping the card
and we're done
now i have my first copy paid with the e
c ny
[Music]
so far the digital union has failed to
resonate i've spoken to a number
of on foreign games participants all of
them either say they do not intend to
use the econy
or some of them you might have heard of
it
[Music]
the near-term goal for the economy is to
popularize it within china but so far
this has met some challenges
first is that the economy is facing
competition from other entrenched mobile
payment platforms another reason is
privacy because it is possible that
every transaction you make can be seen
and be visible to authorities
but china is way ahead in the
development of the digital currency
compared to other countries including
the u.s which is considering its own
digital dollar
[Music]